- I'm James Davis,
and this is Swagasaurus.
Drake and Meek Mill are beefing.
Well actually, Drake beefed
the fuck out of Meek Mill,
and the phrase
"Meeking" was born.
You know what that means?
"Meeking" is when a
person gets upset at you
for not tweeting them,
liking their
Facebook or IG photo,
sharing their post,
texting them back,
or calling them back.
It really means just being
petty on social media.
Now these people, they tend
to go on a rant about you,
start spilling your
business all over the place,
and making stuff up.
The word "meeking" was born,
and the hip hop beat
between Toronto rapper Drake
and Philly rapper Meek Mill.
Oh, Meek Mill.
That's the dude who's dating
Nicki Minaj right now.
So their beef started
with Meek Mill took
offense to Drake
not tweeting his followers to
buy Meek Mill's latest album.
In response, an upset Meek Mill,
then began making allegations
and generally talking
shit about Drake,
until Drake had to release
two separate diss songs
that pretty much ended
that young man's career,
at least for the time being.
None of this would have happened
if Meek Mill wasn't meeking!
It's you're fault, Meek!
Now you're over here getting
bodied by a singing nigga.
The social media pettiness
has to stop, people.
Let people be busy, let
people live their life.
But if you don't
watch Swagasaurus,
I'm gonna be really pissed off.
I'm sorry, look at me.
I'm meeking, I'm meeking.
My bad.
Come back if you want, please.